Now, everything is in place so that you can compute
how to rescue Apollo 13, which is homework too.
You can use sine and cosine to make the moon go around the Earth.
You can use the differential equation to describe the motion of the spacecraft.
You know how to fire the rocket to decelerate the spacecraft
to take it to a low trajectory around the moon and you can compute
by how much to boost the rocket to guarantee a safe return to Earth.
The method to be using for that would be Heun's method
because we need a quite amount of accuracy.
This diagram is really not to scale the Earth and the moon are far more distant as shown here.
This figure 8 loop is much more narrow.
The packing orbit is pretty close to the surface of the Earth.
And this loop around the moon is much closer around the moon as you see here.
Actually, for the stimulation, we have to make this loop around the moon a little wider
to not spend that much computation time on that.